um you guys know that phrase when it
rains it pours
it just won't stop pouring for donald
trump's former lawyer
rudy giuliani there's a new report that
rudy giuliani reportedly called
an arizona official about getting the
election challenge
quote fixed up so that
donald trump would win arizona back
during the 2020 election
now remember that flipping arizona alone
would not have given donald trump the
presidency anyway
remember that rudy giuliani is already
under a major investigation his home and
his office were raided just a few weeks
ago
and now this the arizona republic
revealed
on sunday that rudy giuliani called
the maricopa county supervisor bill
gates
not the microsoft guy just a guy with
the same name on christmas eve of 2020
to introduce himself as the lawyer for
donald trump he left an incredible
message it's almost mafia-like
about getting this situation resolved
for everybody
check out this quote the arizona
newspaper obtained the audio and
published a transcript
rudy left a message saying quote bill
it's rudy giuliani
president trump's lawyer if you get a
chance would you please give me a call
i have a few things a few things i'd
like to talk over with you maybe we can
get this thing
fixed up you know i really think it's a
shame
that republicans sort of are both in
this kind of
situation and i think there may be a
nice way
to resolve this for everybody
why does every rudy giuliani quote
throughout this entire thing
sound like something you'd expect to
hear on the sopranos
not from the lawyer to a sitting
president of the united states
the difference is i would imagine that a
real mobster
wouldn't leave a message like this on a
phone with their real name and speaking
so
uh explicitly about what it is that they
want it would be
you know someone shows up at the house
of this maricopa county supervisor and
says hey
our friend in dc says he wants to talk
about the arizona thing and get it fixed
up
you understand but no rudy just does it
he does it without any hesitation he
just does it via voicemail
and gates has since been asked about the
voicemail and said i never returned
rudy's call
explaining that quote we don't do what
is easy we do what is right
what's scary about that is the
implication that it would have been easy
to just flip the results and give the
state to trump
i hope that's not what supervisor gates
actually means here now many of you have
been emailing me
regularly saying how is rudy not in jail
already there are many answers to that
question the first is people like rudy
don't tend to go to jail
we have a two-tier justice system and
people like rudy
tend not to end up in jail or in prison
second
is that the investigation that's
currently ongoing
was significantly obstructed by trump
appointees to the justice department
when trump was president
they are now coming out and saying biden
got rudy's home in office raided no
actually
the investigation started when trump was
still president and they tried to get a
search warrant all the way back then
but trump appointees in the justice
department obstructed it and blocked it
and prevented it from happening so
this all would have happened under trump
had trump's loyalists in the justice
department not
interfered and third i just don't think
rudy giuliani is going to prison period
and
whenever i say that people are angry or
people say david you should at least
optimistically say let's hope rudy goes
to prison okay
if rudy committed crimes for which he is
found guilty
i hope he's given prison time that would
be a that would be just
uh after everything that he's been
involved in i don't believe rudy's going
to prison
i don't believe trump is going to prison
and so i'm not going to
gaslight you and tell you that i think
that that's a realistic possibility
that's
that's just what it is uh if you
disagree if you think that there's some
real way that rudy giuliani ends up in
prison and to be perfectly frank
even if rudy's charged and doesn't plead
out and is found
guilty um at rudy's age and for this
type of crime
i think that once you get to sentencing
he doesn't get sent to prison
anyway even with multiple guilty
verdicts i just don't see it
okay if you disagree let me know and
we're going to have
more coverage of this on the david
pakman show instagram which you can find
at david pakman show
if you want to see a really wacky and i
mean
weaponized hate mail that i received
last night
find it on my personal instagram
david.pacman alright quick break right
back after this
if you've been watching the show you've
probably heard me talk about how much i
love
my helix mattress well i was really
excited to hear that helix has launched
a new company called all form which
makes premium
customizable sofas and chairs with the
same level of quality and comfort
that i expect from these guys and all
form is one of our sponsors today
they're giving you 20 off at
allforum.com
pacman they actually sent me a couch
which i put in my living room at home
it's now
my favorite piece of furniture in the
house
it took me just minutes to set it up
it's solidly built it's huge it's roomy
it has a modern minimalist design which
i love but it's also
very comfortable fabric is soft clearly
very high quality
it has become the focal point of my
living room
their prices are very reasonable and
when you get a new sofa or chair
you get 100 days to decide if you want
to keep it and the best part is
everything comes with a lifetime
warranty
stop buying poorly made furniture go to
customize
your own all-form sofa or chair right
now and get twenty percent off your
entire order when you get there
by going to all form dot com slash
pacman
i've also put the link right underneath
this video